[Applause]
I know I know I very excited I know why
you're happy just happy to see me
I'm a guy on TV not standing in the rain
that's it's fools in the rain
aren't they fools telling you how
dangerous the storm is while they're
standing in the middle of it the other
millions could be without power yeah
they're called Democrats
the fit look people in the Carolinas are
freaking out over flora Florence not the
hurricane a trans woman using the wrong
bathroom ethic but we wish the best for
the Carolinas they can't hear me they
have no power but the president is on it
he wants you to know that the government
is ready he is monitoring the storm from
the command center in his bed he has
stockpiled tweets and he is prepared to
give himself an A+
and how he handles it and to dispute how
many died in the last storm in Puerto
Rico you see what this [ __ ] did all
week obsessing on the one a year ago
that he [ __ ] up ooh
it was way less than 3000 and the ones
who did die it wasn't from lack of paper
towels I tell you that Trump is saying
that the Democrats inflated the numbers
of dead to make me look bad and if one
thing there is that Donald Trump hates
and somebody who falsely inflates
numbers three million illegals voted for
yes okay does everything have to be
about him that's yeah I mean when he
uses a condom he wears it inside out so
that it's ribbed for his pleasure
I'm joking he's never worn a country but
really Clinton was the I feel your pain
president he's the I am your pain
president and I think he didn't even
know until a few days ago the 3,000
people died in Puerto Rico I think the
staff is always hiding the bad news from
him like when you tell your toddler when
you have to put the dog down that he's
living on a farm looks like that with
Trump and it's like hey where's Michael
Cohen lately he's living on a farm
oh speaking of that speaking of that all
the weather buried the big news Paul
Manafort flipped on fat dog
that's right fat Donny got flipped on by
his former consigliere the campaign
manager Paul Matta 40 is now cooperating
with the Muller team as part of a plea
deal and Muller has gotten plead plea
deals now from manna Forge and Flynn and
gates and Papadopoulos and pecker the
National Enquirer due weiselberger
Trump's longtime lawyer Michael Cohen I
don't want to say Muller is getting
cocky but he showed up in court today
wearing an ostrich jacket I mean Trump's
paranoia level now is just off the chart
I mean is there anyone who wouldn't rat
him out today when he was groping Ivanka
it was just to see if she was wearing a
wire